okay there we go chess reader is the one
i wanted to
accept apparently i haven't played just
reader before
so that's going to be interesting e45
bishop c4 again bishop c5 and here is
the evans can bet that health cheering
was
very very keen on playing
and thus that is what i'm i'm gonna try
my opponent plays very quickly which is
a bit unnerving since i don't really
know
too much about the theory i guess i go i
gotta go queen
b3 right
d6 taken e5 bishop b6 is that supposed
to be the move
yeah i think that is quite correct what
he's doing
don't know what to do here
maybe a4 is reasonable
whenever he goes for this queen goes
away and i'm maybe threatening a5 in
some lines
um okay castles
oh d5 is probably a positional threat
that i'd
that i'd missed there
hmm yeah that's a bit unpleasant
i guess i'll take it not
acting on 92 but i'm just worse
if i keep the queens it feels like i'm
worse as well
let me go 92 try and limit the damage
this is still still definitely worse for
me
if this had been a berlin and he didn't
have the
the right to castle then i would have
been a lot happier
but since you can cancel then i feel
like i'm just
slightly worse and yeah i was a bit of a
bummer
i thought after this move i could go
knight b5 but
there's a pin there so that's not
possible
so i'm rerouting the night
and just trying to
try to be solid
and not lose immediately
but i do have some ideas of growing rook
b1
trying to alleviate the pressure that is
on my
queen side and maybe one day
one very fine day maybe i can't use my
my majority of four against three on
them
and the queen's on the kings side i do
feel as though i definitely equalized
here rook d6 may be coming
some lines and
yeah h3 is useful preparing f3 g4 later
on and it also gives me lift so
i think i'm i'm happier
with the inclusion of um
of these two moves than that he is
um yeah he goes rook c6
that was a bit done i have to say
i didn't need to do that h2
trying to keep the tension he takes
bishop e6
that's very sensible of course
thanks again this is
all looking pretty dryish
yeah very very dryish bitter p4
ripped e5 maybe kind of take the park as
a d7
but after bishop d7 i don't have don't
have much
rookie five you can go rook c8 followed
by rookie
yeah no at least his faces are a bit
passive so i can claim to be
you claim to have some initiative
there should be six i guess i'll go king
of four continued
oh no
crime's name my mouse is working again
and he resigns um
pretty um pretty tough
game there as well